the answers to the question why
interpret dreams are really important so
I'm going to spend some time dealing
with these specific issues in great
detail in brief dreams do the following
dreams provide the most direct access to
unconscious material they compensate and
compliment conscious attitudes they tell
the situation of the psyche as it is at
that very moment dreams are not
distorted by ego defenses
hence provide very accurate information
they provide access to subjective and
inner experiences they provide pure
symbolic or a magic representations of
the archetypes dreams can provide
specific information to the analyst and
dreams are essential diagnostic tools
especially when we deal with neurosis
the last two issues are that dreams
facilitate healing and dreams are
essential to the individuation process
let's examine these ideas in turn first
dreams provide the most direct access to
unconscious material one of the common
products of the unconscious that we all
have access to is the dream it is a
message from the unconscious not from
the ego in this way we can imagine that
each and every night the unconscious
communicates to us in the form of a
dream dreams provide unconscious
contents that compensate or complement
conscious attitudes we have learned
about the process of compensation and
also specifically about the process of
in anti dromio a specific aspect of
compensation the dream attempts to
compensate for the conscious attitudes
we hold it is as if we have a certain
idea about ourselves or about a
situation we find ourselves in and the
unconscious says
okay if that's the position you're
holding let me comment on it I'll give
you a short movie I made for you last
night you can call it a dream but it is
really a feedback movie from me the
unconscious third dreams tell the
situation of the psyche as it is a dream
offers a commentary on the state of the
psyche at that time it gives us direct
feedback about how we are doing
psychically think of the dream as a
short movie or a snapshot of the state
of the psyche the night before there are
some dreams which offer more than that
these are called prospect of dreams
we'll deal with prospective dreams in
due course fourth dreams are not
distorted by eager defenses hence they
provide accuracy Freud's approach to
dreams which we touched on in the last
episode about the difference between a
symbol and a sign relied on a dream
image being treated as a sign in
addition Freud felt that there is a
psychedelic process involved that
distorts the message of the dream from
its latent content to its manifest
content the manifest content of course
for Freud was the actual dream text and
symbol that we could recall the next
morning the psychodynamics involved are
a series of defenses he called the dream
work Jung disagreed and said that there
is no reason for the psyche to distort
the dream or to disguise it the dream is
simply a message that we need some skill
to understand but it isn't heavily
encrypted
to protect the ego so the Union model
does not see that the dream is distorted
so it is remarkably accurate in its
commentary fifth
dreams provide access to subjective
inner experiences this seems quite
obvious to us by now anything that comes
up from my personal unconscious will be
unique to me hence will contain my
subjective experiences important here of
course is that the dream also contains
collective unconscious or archetypal
material sixth dreams provide pure
symbolic aura magic representations of
the archetypes the dreams gives us
access to archetypal images in their
pure form later episodes will deal with
another source of pure archetypal mere
material and that is the fairy tale what
we need to recognize about our dream at
this stage is that when we recall the
symbols of the dream that these symbols
are archetypal images number seven
certain dream material may present
prospect of imagery or messages from the
unconscious a form of a dream that we
may occasionally experience is the
prospect of dream in which a statement
is made about a future conscious
attitude I'll deal with this more when
we discuss the types of Dreams we have
in one of the future episodes eight
dreams can provide specific information
to the analyst
those of you in analysis or considering
an analysis with a Jungian analyst
realize how critical dreams are to the
whole analytic process as the analyst
and the patient worked together on the
analytic material not only the egos are
involved there is a vast storehouse of
information about the patient and the
analysts psyches that derives from dream
material dreams that relate directly to
the analytic encounter offer crucial
information about the transference and
countertransference
sessions and thereby contribute to
correcting the work that is being done
nine dreams are central to the analytic
process as mentioned above dreams can
correct the analytic situation there may
be a situation in which the analyst is
incorrect in his or her assessment of a
situation in the patient's life or is
not dealing with the transference in the
optimum manner the patient dream will
often be a direct statement about this
this fact is really quite incredible
imagine being in analysis and feel that
something is being missed in the
analytic encounter and that night you're
unconscious produces a dream that states
exactly what the issue is you then take
it to the next analytic session
interpret the dream with the analyst and
have the situation corrected in other
words your unconscious makes a direct
comment on your analysis those of you
that have experienced this will know
that this correction certainly does
happen and it is a truly fascinating
phenomenon ten dreams are diagnostic
tools especially with neurosis we are
all of us neurotic to some degree dreams
can give very good information about the
neurotic way we live out our lives
the difficulty with severe neurotic
conditions is that apart from being
excruciatingly ly painful these
conditions are often quite resistant to
change it is through the dream that
change is suggested and encouraged
because and this brings me to my next
point number eleven dreams facilitate
healing the way out of certain painful
positions that we are holding
consciously can be healed or worked
through by a dream or a series of dreams
most of us have experienced this at some
stage
we are stuck between two very difficult
positions or decisions in our lives and
feel incapable of deciding either way
then a dream appears with a powerful
symbol contained in it that helps us
find another way or the third way and
lastly number 12
dreams are essential to the
individuation process finally dreams are
central to this process of individuation
which briefly is the progressive
unfolding of the personality in such a
way that you become an individual
authentic and secure in your way of
being in the world as dreams correct our
eager stance and offer vital information
from the rest of the psyche we know that
the dream is central to this whole
individuation process so there we have
12 good reasons to interpret dreams